مستمرون مشاهدينا دائما معكم في تغطيه هذه
التطورات التي تاتينا من تركيا في الواقع
في اسطنبول بالتحديد انفجار شهدته مشاهده
ميدان تقسيم وشارع الاستقلال هذه هي صور
التي سنبقى في متابعتها ونذكر بانه في اخر
التطورات او على الاقل في اخر الاخبار
التي اوردها حاكم اسطنبول عبر تغريده وليس
عبر بيان رسمي حاكم اسطنبول اكد بان حصيله
هذا الانفجار حتى الان اربعه قتله و 38
جريح في انفجار منطقه تقسيم مشاهدينا نحن
نتحدث عن اسطنبول اي عن همم العاصمه
الاقتصاديه والسياحيه التركيه نتحدث كذلك
عن ميدان تقسيم وهو منطقه جدا سياحيه في
اسطنبول
وشارع الاستقلال او جادت الاستقلال هي من
الشوارع التي اقتظ عاده بالسياح في هذه
الفتره من السنه نبقى في متابعه هذه الصور
نحاول ان نفهم ما يحدث مع ضيفنا من
اسطنبول المحلل السياسي
جواد اهلا بك معنا هل هناك اشتباهات اوليه
طيب ضيفنا سيعود لنا بعد قليل السيد مصطفى
اوزجان الان المحلله السياسيه معنا سيد
مصطفى همم حتى ولو كان الوقت مبكر نسبيا
ولكن هل هناك اشتباهات اوليه من من مصلحته
احداث همم زعزعه همم في داخل التركي في
هذا التوقيت
يعني سياسيون في تركيا
هل هناك هل هناك يشتباعات وراء هذه
العمليه يعني لم يشير الى اي مناظر منظمات
محتمله هي ارهابيه في هذا المجال او في
هذا الحادث
طبعا الخبراء همم يعني همم
بعض همم بعض التعليقات حول هذا الموضوع
يمكن ان يكون طبعا همم
هذه العمليه لان همم
كانت بعد مثل هذه العمليه العمليات
قصه مرتبطه طبعا بلا اجنحه السياسيه لان
لها اعصاب سياسيه هيلعب ليست فقط احداث
عسكريه ولكن احتساب السياسه نعم هل يمكن
همم ان همم
يريد او تريد تحقيق شعر تركي او توجيه
تركي
ولكن احداث سياسيه من اي شكل
بلبله بلبله همم
لانهم مقيم على همم
التقاط الانتخابي في هذه في هذه الاسماء
همم
واثاره البنك يمكن ان يكون عنده مصلحه
فيهم يعني هذا يؤدي الى صراع اكثر بين
القتلتين همم
لانه هناك اصلا همم
يعني يريد هذه العلاقه هذه التواصل بين
هذه القضيه كاش بين السياسيين في تركيا
وضحت هذه الفكره والاكيد باننا سنبقى في
متابعه هذه الحسابات السياسيه وهذه
التطورات وعلاقتها بما تطرح حظرتك من
تفاصيل سياسيه ولكن البعض كذلك يطرح
استفهامات امنيه همم كيف اللي قنبله
والاخبار على الاقل وليا الغير رسميه همم
تقول باننا نتحدث عن قنبله داخل الحقيبه
هي التي همم انفجرت في همم شارع الاستقلال
او جهادات الاستقلال كيف يقنبله ان تصل
الى هذه المنطقه همم
ونحن نعلم بانه هذا الشارع يعني مؤمن
بدرجه همم كبيره
ليس هناك
نعم يعني ان ما يحدث
هل تدابير الامنيه على مفصل
لهذا الشهر ولكن
لذلك الذين تحدث
نبض همم
تركيا نستطيع ان نقول لذلك
اتفاق همم لها عبايات مختلفه يمكن ان يكون
اذا اختفت سياسيه همم ونحن تحدث استاذه
مصطفى نشير كذلك لاننا في متابعه لهذه
الصور الصور التي تاتينا من ميدان تقسيم
من شارع الاستقلال بتحديد ويبدو حاكم
اسطنبول ربما وهناك كذلك مجموعه من
مرافقيه همم
يتقدمون همم باتجاه موقع الانفجار على كل
همم ان كان جاهز معي السيد جاك
طيب نحن نتابع رئيس بلديه اسطنبول اكرم
اوغلو رئيس بلديه اسطنبول في كلمه امامه
صحفيين بعد هذا الانفجار نتحدث عن انفجار
شهيده شارع الاستقلال ليس هناك بيان رسمي
حتى الان يضعنا في اطار تفاصيل همم رسميه
ولكن حاكم اسطنبول عبر تغريده تحدث حتى
الان عن اربعه
وثلاثين همم ان كان هناك صوت طبيعي او
ربما نعود بعد قليل محتوى اا هذه
التصريحات نبقي عينا في كل الحالات على
هذا المشهد وهذه الصور الحيه لرئيس بلديه
اسطنبول واعود لك من جديد استاذ مصطفى كنت
حدثني عن تامين هذه المنطقه في الواقعه
استفهامات كبيره بخصوص تامينها ولكن
نتحدث كذلك عن حسابات جديده يعني منذ قليل
الملفت في التصريحات او على الاقل تفاعلات
الدوليه حتى الان مع ما يحدث كان هناك
تصريحات عن الاعلام او ردتها وسائل
الاعلام اسرائيليه تقول بان الخارجيه
الاسرائيليه تتحرى وجود مصابين اسرائيليين
في تفجير اسطنبول بعد ذلك الخارجيه
الاسرائيليه كانت اكدت بانها لم تفقد
الاتصال مع اي اسرائيلي في اسطنبول طرح
فكره ان يكون هناك نزاع ايراني اسرائيلي
بعد مشادات بين الطرفين على ارض تركيا الى
اي مدى هذا وارد
بعض الخلايا النائمه بنسبه المخابرات هي
قد قامت باستهاب الاسرائيليين ولكن تنباع
السلطان السلطان التركي قبل وقوع
النائمه الذين
ان شاء الله
ربما صدفه ان يكون بين اسرائيل
اوه المحلله السياسيه سيد فائق اهلا بك
معنا همم التوقيت همم هل يلفت لشيء ما هذه
المرحله التي تعيشها تركيا تحضيرات
للانتخابات وهمم تركيا كذلك اليوم هي همم
وسيط في عده ملفات دوليه توقيت هذا
الانفجار يدل على ماذا بالتحديد
يعني
حاليا ممكن همم
اغطيه الانباء ونشر الانباء بهذا خصوص
لمده معينه وهذا يدل على ان هناك هذا يشار
ليس عادي ولكن ممكن ان كل سياسي او ارحابي
في اطار اي شيء جديد ولكن استاذ ثائر همم
البصمه تشبه بصمه من المجموعات او من
الاطراف التي لها مصلحه في ان يتم ذلك في
تركيا في هذا التوقيت
لكل الاحتمالات قد تكون يعني جهه الداخليه
قاعده يعني
غير مؤكده
الخارج داخليه
مدعومه من الدوله معينه دوله اجنبيه معينه
غير معروف
ذلك يعني
مصطفى صحيح انه ردد جيد ولكن يعني بالنسبه
للسؤال يا سيده انه هل
اعتقد ايران تقوم بهذا الشيء بحيث انه هذه
التخرب العلاقات
التركيه وانما سؤالي كان همم استنادا على
ما طرحته الخارجيه الاسرائيليه بانها تبحث
في موضوع ان كان هناك اسرائيليين ومن هنا
اتسؤال
يعني انفجار معينه يعني لها طبعا همم ممكن
نقول يعني فرتكه فرتكه الجرائم كثيره بحق
الشعب الفلسطيني او الباحث العرب وبالتالي
يعني
يتعتقد سمعت برنامج
تبحث عن هذه الامور هذه طيب وهذا طبيعي
لان النت طبعا مواطنه ولكن غير ذلك انا لا
اعتمر شوف كيف يعني يعني اذا اذا فيها
تبينت ممكن
الصور منذ قليل في الواقع كنا نتابع صور
مكان الحقيبه التي استاذ فائق خليك معي لو
سمحت لي ساعود لك بعد قليل ان كنت تسمعني
فقط وددت الاشاره هذه هي الصور التي كنا
نتبعها منذ قليل هي همم صور المكان الذي
همم انفجر بالتحديد المكان الذي قيل فيما
بعد بان حقيبه همم وجدت فيه وهذه الحقيبه
تظننت عبوه ناسفه وهي همم الحقيبه التي
انفجرت وادت باربعه قتل حتى الان وثمان
وثلاثين همم جريح همم سيد فائق كنت تتحدث
عن تامين هذه المنطقه
سعيد فايق تسمعني
طيب انا فقدنا الاتصال مع الاستاذ فايق
بولوت نحاول العوده لها بعد قليل ولكن
استاذ مصطفى كنت اسمعني وان كنت تتابع
معنا هذه التطورات ممتاز طيب كنا نتابع
صور المكان الذي وضعت في هذه الحقيبه ولكن
الكل يعلم بانه من يدخل الى جده الاستقلال
او حتى الى ميدان تقسيم ليست هناك عمليه
تفتيش فرديه يعني الكل يدخل الكل يمكنه
زياره هذه المنطقه ومن السهل ان يحمل اي
احد معه شيء في حقيبته قادر ان اا يؤثر في
همم الامن العام وكذلك ان يحدث ازرار
وبالتالي لماذا في هذه المرحله هناك لون
نقراه حتى على مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي
على ال همم تشديدات الامنيه في منطقه
تقسيم بالتحديد ما الداعي ذلك
عده
اخبار
عمليه
عمليات غير العربيه
كل المواطنين الذين جرحوا في هذا التفجير
بعد قليل
اجتماع المجموعه ال20
جاري
التخلص من اثار الجانبيه
الان هناك نقاشات حول
الامن الغذائي وان تتناول هذه الملفات
في الاجتماعات الحرب
الروسيه همم
ااا ستكون ايضا من ضمن الملفات التي
سنناقشها هناك
وموجه التضخم التي تؤثر
العالم ايضا سيتم تناولها
في بيان انطاليا لمجموعه العشرين كنا قد
اكدنا على
موضوع
تقليص
النفايات
لرئيس تركيه رشاد طيب اردوغان كنا ننتظر
في الواقع تصريحات همم تتعلق
بهذه العمليه ولكن هو كان يتحدث عن اجتماع
انطاليا ربما فيما بعد ان كان سيتوقف عند
هذه العمليه ويتحدث عنها سنعود له ولكن
نعلم بانه نحن في وقت مبكر همم معلومات
صحيحه فقط تعلق اردوغان بالقول بانه سنكشف
عن منفذي انفجار تقسيم ولكن همم اكيد
ستبقى عيننا على اي بيان رسمي يضعنا في
اطار ماء سيحدث حتى الان بحسب حاكم
اسطنبول سته قتله وثلاث وخمسون جريحا في
انفجارا منطقه تقسيم اذا نذكر بانه همم
بحسب حاكم اسطنبول وظهر بانها تغريده اخرى
لحكم اسطنبول سته قتلى و53 جريحا فانفجار
منطقه تقسيم همم سيد مصطفى همم هناك اصابع
اتهام في الواقع وحاول ان اتابع تفاعلات
الاتراك كذلك مع ما يحدث تحدثنا عن حزب
العمال الكردستاني يتحدثنا عن داعش ولكن
البعض يطرح فكره الاخوان والموقف الاخير
من تركيا تجاه الاخوان في محاوله منها
لعوده او تمثيل علاقاتها مع الدول المنتقه
هل يمكن ان تشبه هذه البصمه لبصمه الاخوان
تعتقد
والله
على اساس علاقات حتى الان يعني جيده مع
الاخوان ربما تركيا
بين تركيا همم
مع مع رئيس يسافر الى هناك الى هذه
المدينه للهدور همم لبعض الاجتماعات حتى
سماع حدثت في اسطنبول لا اعتقد ان هناك
تتسابق بين المدينتين وهمم والضالي ولكن
همم يعني همم مفارقه عجيبه بعيده طيب
استاذ مصطفى بحسب قربك للمشهد ومعرفتك
كذلك بكل هذه تطورات همم متى من المنتظر
سنكون امام بيان رسمي يضعنا في اطار اا
التفاصيل يعني همم خاصه انا همم ميدان
تقسيم شهد في ما قبل عمليه الارهابيه
وانفجار كذلك في سنه 2010 بحسب ما اعتقد
انقر كذلك شهدت في 2015 عمليه مثله
وبالتالي همم كم من الوقت تقريبا سنكون
بعد امام التفاصيل رسميه
والله طبعا ااا هناك تكتمل من السلطات
تركيا فرض طبعا
في اقرب وقت
ممكن سيكون هناك معلومات
الاشعه يعطي
سمعه الحكومه اكثر مما
ينفع
يا استاذ مصطفى لمن التحق بنا الان وذاكر
باننا في تغطيه الانفجار اسطنبول نتحدث عن
المدينه الاقتصاديه السياحيه الاولى في
تركيا الانفجار شهيده ميدان تقسيم
وبالتحديد شارع الاستقلال او جادت
الاستقلال وفي هذه المرحله من السنه هناك
طبعا تحضيرات للاعياد وتركيا تعيش على وقع
هذه التحضيرات وهناك في عموم السنه في
الواقعه هناك كثافه همم للسياح في هذه
المنطقه وبالتحديد في هذا همم هذه الفتره
كذلك من السنه منذ قليل كونان نتبع همم
هذه الصور هذه الصور اتت بعد الانفجار
ولكن هذه هي بالفعل هذه صور الانفجار من
كاميرا مراقبه
اذا هذه هي الصور الاوليه لانفجار ينضم
لنا المحلله السياسي اوكتايه يلمع السيد
اهلا بك معنا من من مصلحه
الوضع الداخلي الامن التركي
هل تسمعني
طيب فقدنا الاتصال مع الدكتور
الى الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان الذي
اكد منذ قليل ما كتبه حاكم اسطنبول
ارهابيه او وفقا لمقاله لانه يشتم رائحه
الهجمه الارهابيه بحسب كلام والي اسطنبول
طبعا هنا سيتم مراقبه الكاميرا
وستتم ايضا همم
الابحاث والتحقيقات
عن هويه هذا التفكير
ينفع
اسم عمر
بالتحدث الى الرئيس بعيدا بمجموعه العشرين
حول هذا الموضوع
مركز دلائل
ربما يريد ان يحور كلامنا
فتح الله
الولايات المتحده وانا قلت له عندما كان
نائب الرئيس الامريكي الرئيس بيضا الرئيس
الحريري الولايات المتحده
نحن قلنا لهم في ذلك الوقت ان عندما طلبتم
القس
الامريكي المحتجز لدينا اعطيناكم اياه
لماذا لا تعطونا القصه همم بتاعنا او قصنا
المشاهدين
رجب طيب اردوغان يؤكد بان تفجير تقسيم
باسطنبول هو عمليه ارهابيه تحدث كذلك هو
في الواقع لم يطرح الفكره ولكن اجابه على
سؤال احد الصحفيين الذي وضع فرضيه ان يكون
هذا التفجير همم من اتباع فتح الله همم
يقول همم رئيس التركي بانه على الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه تسليم همم فتح همم
ونعلم بانه هذا الموضوع همم يعني همم طويل
وقديم وهناك تفاصيل كثيره وتصريحات
متبادله من الطرفين بخصوص التسليم من عدمه
لي تركيا ولكن سابقى مع تاكيد رئيس تركيا
كون هذه العمليه هي عمليه ارهابيه سيد
اكثر المحلل السياسي همم سيد اقطعي اهلا
بك معنا كنا نت دافعه فرضيه ولكن همم
فصلها الرئيس التركي واكد باننا بيتنا
نتحدث عن واقع وقال بان هذه العمليه هي
عمليه ارهابيه من من مصلحته مثل هكذا
عمليه في تركيا
على سبيل المثال قبل سبع سنوات موجه من
همم اعمال همم من العمليات اراديه مماثله
قامت بها في تلك الفتره همم
منظمه المتطرفه تعيش او همم
كردستان العراق طبعا هذا
التنظيمالي الرئيسي يعني اتصال اتصال
تركيا منذ الفتره همم
كيف قال لرابي منذ عقود منذ حوالي همم
اربعه نقود وتنظيم الطعش منذ عقد من الزمن
تستهدف في مثل هذه الاعمال الارهابيه همم
استقرار البلاد طبعا لا استطيع
الكردستاني في هذه المرحله بالتحديد ان
كنت تسمعني فقط
حزب العمال الكردستاني في هذا التوقيت
بالتحديد همم من وراء هكذا عمليه ولكن قبل
اجابه حظرتك نشير الى اننا في متابعه
لقوات الامن التركيه بعد اغلاقها
لجاه الاستقلال او شارع الاستقلال من
الجاني بين هذا الشارع الذي همم شهد هذا
الانفجار الذي اكد الرئيس التركي رجب طيب
اردوغان انه نتج عن قنبله واردوغان كذلك
الرئيس التركي في ريحتها اا اكد ان امراه
ضالعه بهجوم تقصير في اسطنبول وبان
التحقيقات ما زالت جريا كما نتابع اسفل
الشاشه اذا اريس تركيا رجب طيب اردوغان
يقول ان امراه تنهيه الضاليا في هذا
التفجير ولان الهجمات الارهابيه هدفها
اسقاط الدوله بحسب تصريحات دائما الرئيس
التركي هذه هي الصور التي كنا نتحدث عنها
منذ قليل الامن التركي يغلق جوده
الاستقلال من الجانبين هذا الشارع همم جد
حيوي في الواقع في هذه الفتره من السنه
وفي كل العالم كل سنه حقيقه همم وهو منطقه
سياحيه مشاهدينا بامتياز وهذه المنطقه
شهدت عمليه الان يمكن القول بانها عمليه
ارهابيه طبعا هذا ما اكده الرئيس التركي
اعود لك من جديد استاذ
كنت حدثني عن همم من من مصلحته وحضرتك
تحدثت عن حزب العمال الكردستاني ولكن حزب
العمال همم ما همم دواء فعافي هذه المرحله
بتحديد همم من وراء هكذا عمليه ان همم
طبعا سلمنا جدلا بدقه ما تتفضل به على
الاقل كطرح
عن المنظمات التي
تركي بها العمال
المنظمه
الرئيسيه همم الاساسيه التي في تركيا ولكن
لا استطيع طبعا همم تسميه هذه المنظمه في
هذا الحادث همم بالضبط همم يعني هناك ما
زالت البحث وهمم وجاريه كما تعلمين كذلك
ان يتحدث عن المنظمات
ولكن هو البحث جاري ولكن حتى تامين
المنطقه مستمر نحن نلاحظ على يسار شاشه
هناك قوات امنيه تتوجهها الان وكانت هناك
في الواقعه مخاوف من ان تكون هناك عمليه
ارهابيه ثانيه او همم انفجار سنن وهذا
وارد بحسب كثيرين ما راي حضرتك
يعني احيانا هذا هو اسلوب
المنظمات العراقيه يحدث الانفجار الاول
بعد دقائق الساعات يكون هناك انفجارات
اخرى هذا حصل في اسطنبول قبل حوالي سبع
سنوات في منطقه
اسالنا همم
وبعد دقائق
حشرات من المدنيه همم هذه المنطقه تعتبر
منطقه التقسيم وهذه خاصه يعني استقلال
قلبي
همم في المدينه منطقه سياحيه همم
يعني همم
الدوله لا تسق
هذه ايمان الارهابيه ولكن الهدف بعد
الاستقلال
ماذا ينضمنا مراسل العربيه زيدان زين كلو
زيدان اهلا بك معنا هل من جديد في الواقع
في اخر تصريحات رئيس تركيا اكد على ان
امراه هي التي كانت وراء هجوم تقسيم او
خلينا نقول انفجار تقسيم همم واكد باننا
امام ستت قتلى اكثر من 50 جريح وهمم بانها
عمليه ارهابيه فصلها اردوغان بوصفها
ارهابيه ونحن في انتظار التحقيقات
والابحاث هل من جديد او من تفاصيل اضافيه
نعم فعلا
التكهنات التي كانت تسري قبل تصريحات
اردوغان خرج الرئيس التركي
ليؤكد بانها عمليه ارهابيه وان امراه
شاركت او لها صله بهذا الموضوع طبعا
المؤشرات الاولى التي كانت ما قبل تصريحات
اردوغان
والتسريبات التي همم ذكرتها بعض وسائل
الاعلام ان الشرطه التركيه وخلال مراقبتها
الانفجار والدقق التي سبقت الانفجار كانت
تتحدث عن انفجار ناجم عن القنبله همم
موضوع داخل حقيبه همم في شارع او كانت
موجوده هذه حقيقه حقيقه في شان الاستقلال
الشرطه بنت هذه الموضوع على ان المنطقه
التي شهدت الانفجار كان فيها مجموعه من
الحقائب او مجموعه من المره الذين يحملون
حقائب لذلك قاعده ترجيحات الاولى تشير الى
هذه النقطه طبعا الرئيس لم يذكر هذا
الموضوع همم
لن يكون هناك مليحين اجتماع التحقيقات او
الوصول الى جواب دقيقه على هذا الموضوع
لكن اذا كان هو الرئيس التركي هو فعلا
انها كانت عمليه ارهابيه همم امراه هي
كانت من وراء همم وراء هذا الهجوم همم
طبعا العدد الضحايا كما ذكر بس ست قتله
وايضا حوالي همم او بالضبط 53 او 53 مصابا
هم عدد الجرحى في هذا همم الانفجار حتى
الان همم اسباب الانفجار السلطات التركيه
لم تدلي بسبع او ببيان رسمي حول اسباب
الانفجار وما ذكره الرئيس
تفجير همم سببه عبوه وكنا حتى شاهدنا في
الواقع زيدان شاهدنا الصور الاوليه لهذا
الانفجار ولكن همم نحن امامنا صور زيدان
اللي همم شارع همم تقسيم لميدان تقسيمه
شارع الاستقلال همم انت اقرب لمختلف مناطق
الاخرى في همم في اسطنبول اتحدث هل هناك
تامين لمناطق اخرى هل هناك مخاوف من ان
تكون هناك او ان تشهد اسطنبول عمليه اخرى
لان بعض المراقبين يقولون
عمليه اولى فربما هناك تحضير لعمليه ثانيه
لقدر الله فهل هناك تامين لمناطق اكثر من
غيرها
الاماكن السياحيه هي بالدرجه الاولى تكون
مؤمنه بشكل كامل من قبل قوات الامن التركي
والشرطه التركيه من ضمنها طبعا كانت منطقه
ميدان تقسيمه شارع الاستقلال لا شك الان
هناك اجراءات امنيه اخرى في مناطق اساسيه
في اسطنبول سياسيه منطقه السلطان احمد وهي
المنطقه التي شهدت مطلع عام 2016 اول
التفجيرات التي عادت الى اسطنبول همم في
همم او الاماكن السياحيه في اسطنبول ومن
ثم كان هناك عده انفجارات في اسطنبول
بينها كان هناك انفجار في شارع الاستقلال
في مارس 2016 ايضا لذلك طبعا هناك اجراءات
امنيه في كثير من المناطق الاماكن
السياحيه التي همم خلال سنوات الماضيه همم
استهدفتها اعمال ارهابيه همم نتحدثنا عن
منطقه السلطان احمد منطقه
كلها اماكن سياحيه همم في اسطنبول تشه
دائما الاكتضاض ااا من السياح ومن الزوار
او حتى من القاطنين في تلك المناطق او حتى
العاملين في سته المناطق كنا هذه المنطقه
مناطق سياحيه همم طبعا السلطات الامنيه
همم هناك المخاوف الامنيه طالما ان الحديث
عن عمليه ارهابيه دائما يتم التكهم
بسناريوهات ربما تكون اسوا وان شاء الله
لا يكون هناك سيناريوهات اسوا لكن دائما
همم السلطات الامنيه همم تفترض همم
الاسوا وتتصرف بناء على ذلك بناء على همم
السيناريوهات
التي يتم بها بها ثم رفع حاله الجاهليه
وتكثيف همم
انتشار الامني في بعض المناطق همم واتحدث
زيدان ان كنت تسمعني اا همم في انتظار
طبعا اي شيء رسمي وفي ظل شرح المعلومات هل
هناك بعض المعلومات الاضافيه عن هويه
القتلى اوضحايا او الجرحه
زيدان
هل تسمعني
نتحدث عن الجنسيات جنسيات القتلى او
الجرحى هل تبين شيء جديد في ما يخص هذا
الموضوع
من تل ابيب
او هذا الخبر كان قبل حوالي عدم وجود
اسرائيلي
من ضمن الضحايا همم
على ما اعتقد انك سالت بهذا السؤال لان
الصوت همم نعم لا شك ان المعلومات لان
السلطات التركيه فرضا على
همم طلبه حصل على وسائل الاعلام بنشر اي
معلومات تتعلق بالانفجار سوى ما يصدر عن
همم
المصادر الرسميه هذا الحظر اصدره المجلس
الاعلى للاذاعه والتلفزيون في تركيا قبل
حوالي الساعه ونصف من الان
طيب تفضل بالبقاء معنا او ربما نعود لك في
السياق هذه هي التغطيه زيدان زين كلو
مراسله العربيه شكرا جزيلا لك حتى الان
اعود من جديد الى ضيفه كان جاهز همم معنى
او باقي معنا تسمعني استاذ مصطفى
يقول بان همم هذه الهجمات الارهابيه هدفها
اسقاطه الدوله التركيه ما الذي يعنيها
رئيس تركيا من همم هذا التصحيح خاصه همم
اننا همم اا يعني على بعد بعض الاشهر او
سته اشهر من الانتخابات الرئاسيه التي
ستحتضنها تركيا بين اعتقد منتصف يونيو
واوائل يوليو من سنه 2003 2020 هل يقصد
التشويش على الانتخابات القادمه او شيء
اخر
ولكن
هذه العمليه منظمات مثل الهجره الثانيه
بهذه القضيه همم
اذا كان هذا اذا كان هذا صحيح انما لان
المعلومات حتى الان لا تؤكد بانه تم
اعتقالها
يعني هناك
حول هذا الموضوع اذا كانت هناك وراء هذه
العمليه مانعه هذا اذا هذه العمليه اقرب
الى عمليه
منذ قليل بالفعل اكد بان هناك امراه هي
التي تقف وراء هذا الانفجار ربما بوضعها
هذه الحقيبه التي همم تحتوي هذه القنبله
ولكن قلت لي بانه ربما قد تم اعتقال هذه
السيده همم بناء على ايه مصادر همم
اذا كانت همم هناك امراه اقرب الى مجموعه
حزب مجموعات مثاليه
وحلل هكذا لان
مثال الدواجن نساء من كميات لدواعش لا
يقومون عاديسا هذه الاعمال ولكن الحزب
المالك لديهم خواطر النساء
اذا كانت هذا اذا كان هذا الخبر صحيح على
انها همم يهدوا الاموال
مصطفى يعني حضرتك ليه الصوره تقول بان همم
لا ترى بصمه لداعش في هذه العمليه ولكن
ترى بصمه واضحه لحزب العمال الكردستاني
كونه كما في الشارع الرئيسي ايوه واضح
اشارات فقط
لديه مجموعات من النساء متدربات على مثل
هكذا عمليات هذا ما قلتها ولكن همم الملفت
كذلك بان من بين الاسئله التي طرحها
صحفيون على رئيسه تركي همم كان هناك تركيز
على فتح الجولان المعارض البارز لرئيس
التركي لماذا همم بحسب قراءتك
همم
سياسي حول هذا الموضوع ولكن همم طبعا همم
ان هذه المجموعه عفوا وان كانت ارهابيه
همم تركيا تركيا
او همم
لم يحدث حتى الان يعني ليس لديهن مثل هذه
الحوادث لم تقوم مثل هذه الحوادث السابقه
لذلك همم تتحدث تتحدث عن اي دي فتح الله
صحيح تقول بانه ليس لديه التاريخ في
القيامه
السابقه
هذا يعني نعم هم محاوله للقيام بانقلاب
العسكري ايضا حكومه
يعني
مثل هذه الاعمال
هو لماذا طرحت سؤال او نقلت على الاقل
سؤال الصحفي همم
متعلق ب فتح الله جلن اتحدث عن سؤال
المتعلق بالمعارض له رئيس اردوغان فتح
الله لان الرئيس اردوغان نفسه تحدث عن همم
ان هذه التفجيرات همم سببها او على الاقل
هدف منها هو تهديد النظام ويقول بانه لن
تسقط النظام فان كنا سنتحدث عن فتح الله
فهذا يبدو اكثر منطقيا ما قاله الرئيس همم
اردوغان او ما رايت صعيد مصر
هم مسؤولون الدوله لربما لديهم لدى حوزتهم
بعض المعلومات
تقول المملكه تدين التفجير الذي استهدفها
منطقه التقسيم في اسطنبول اذا عن الخارجيه
السعوديات المملكه تدين التفجير الذي
استهدفها منطقه تقسيم في اسطنبول وستبقى
عيننا على هذا العواجل ينضم لنا الان
اسماعيل كايا الصحفي اهلا بك سيد اسماعيل
هل توفرت بعض الاخبار او التفاصيل
الاضافيه حتى الان
يعني احدث ما نشر حتى الان رسميا وتصريح
الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان قبل قليل
الذي اكد وقوع ست قتلى و53 جريح في هذا
التفجير وقال انه على الاغلب التسجيل
ارهابي لم يلزم بنسبه 100% ولكن قال كل
المعطيات الامنيه والتحقيقات حتى الان
تشير الى انه تفجير ارهابي وربما هناك
سيده لها دور مباشر في هذا التفجير بعد
مقاطع الفيديو اظهرت السيده ربما تترك
قنبله او او تفجر نفسها في وسط المدنيين
الذين كانوا يرتدون شارع الاستقلال
السياحي الشهير في اسطنبول وبالتالي كل
المؤشرات
تحتوي قنبله لم تفجر نفسها
يعني حتى الان لا يوجد جزء نهائي حول هذا
الامر ولكن هناك فصل زمن قصير جدا يرجع
انها كانت في دائره
الاوليه نحن كنا نتبعها وهناك صوره لحقيبه
وهذه الحقيبه موجوده في الشارع خارج
المحلات
وفيما بعد حدث الانفجار وهذا ما اكد هو
البعض بان هناك حقيبه هذه الحقيبه احتوت
على قنبله انفجرت
قنبله ليست صغيره او وقعت هذا العدد
الكبير من القتلى والجرحى ولكن تبقى
الكلمه الفصل لتحقيقات النهائيه للجهات
الامنيه التي ستعلن التفاصيل لاحقا المؤكد
ان هناك تفجير وتفجير همم كبير ناتج عن
قنبله او انتحار لم يتم الجزم بذلك بشكل
نهائي من الجهات الامنيه والجهات الرسميه
وهناك عدد من الضحايا وصل الى همم 53 جريح
هناك بعض الجرح ربما في حالات خطيره ربما
تزيد العقيله لاحقا وكما شاهد الجميع
المستهدف هو المدنيين ولا يوجد في المنطقه
هدف عسكري او امني او هدف محدد هو ان هذا
التفجير كان يهدف الى ايقاع عدد كبير من
الضحايا في صفوف المدنيين كما تعلمون شارع
الاستقلال هو شارع سياحي يرتدوا الالاف في
يوم مشمس في يوم عطله اسبوعيا في همم في
هذا التوقيت كان الهدف واضح انه اختير
التوقيت لايق اكبر من الضحايا في صفوف
المدنيين كل الضحايا والمصابين هم من
المدنيين الذين كانوا يرتدون هذا الشارع
السياحي المزحم وبالتالي الهدف كان ايقاع
عدد كبير من الضحايا ولا يوجد هدف امني
محدد يمكن وضع التفجير في اطار اخر في
هذا السياق وكل ذلك يؤشر الى ان هذا
التفجير وقع على طراز الكثير من التفجيرات
التي استهدفت اسطنبول وانقره والعديد من
العواصم والمدن السياحيه الكبرى في اوروبا
وفي تركيا بين عامي 2015 16 17 حتى ولكن
في تركيا منذ عام نهايه عام 2016 استضاعت
الاجهزه الامنيه التركيه همم وضع حد لمثل
هذه الهجمات واذا بالفعل ثبت ان ذلك هو
تفجير ارهابي فانه سيكون اول الهجوم يقع
في تركيا منذ نهايه عام 2016 وبالتالي
يتحدث عن همم محاوله ارهابيه على طوال
السنوات الماضيه كان هذه المره يبدو ان
تنظيم ارهابي معين همم قد تمكن من تنفيذ
هذا الهجوم وكما تعلمون هذا النوع من
الهجمات نفذتها سابقا سواء تنظيم داعش
الارهابي او تنظيم بيكاكا الارهابي هذا
النوع من الهجمات استهداف في المدنيين
وايقاع ضحايا في صفوف المدنيين هي هجمات
نفذتها في السابق تنظيمات داعش وبيكاكا
ويعتقد ان هذه الجهات هي من نفذت هذه
الهجوم ايضا هذه المره
استاذ اسماعيل هل يمكن ان يكون او ان يكون
امام اكثر من تفجير لانه همم حقيقه الرئيس
التركي وحاكم اسطنبول كذلك من قبل يتحدث
عن عبوه الناسفه ولكن همم بعض همم يعني
المتفاعلين على مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي
همم
بصدد نشر همم فيديو همم امراه كما تفضلت
بالاشاره تقطع الطريق تقف ومن ثم همم همم
يحدث الانفجار هل نحن امام انفجار واحد
امام انفجارين
والمؤكد حتى الانفجار واحد
300 حتى ميدانيا كمان نحن قريبون من
الميدان لا يوجد اي انفجارات اخرى هو هجوم
واحد فقط عباره عن انفجار لم يتم الجزم
بطبيعته بعد ولكن عن الارجح هو رب- عبوه
ناسفه واحده وانفجار واحد وقع في اسطنبول
اليوم فقط
هو تامين مختلف المراكز والمناطق همم
السياحيه في مختلف همم المناطق في اسطنبول
يعني كما تعلمون اسطنبول مدينه كبيره
وضخمه مدينه امنه لم تقع فيها اي هجمات
منذ سنوات طويله كما ذكرت في بين عامي
2014 حتى 2016 شهدت العديد من العواصم
والمدن الكبرى في اوروبا وتركيا موجه من
هجمات تنظيم داعش الارهاب الذي استهدف
محطات قطارات ومؤسسات واماكن عامه وشوارع
سياحيه في العديد من المدن حول العالم
ولكن في تركيا بشكل محدد منذ نهايه عام
2016 وتحديدا هجوم الملهى الليلي في
اسطنبول نهايه عام 2016 لم تقع عليها
جماعه اخرى وبالتالي الوضع الامني في
تركيا ولا يوجد اي هجمات على مدى سنوات
الماضيه ويبدا ان هذا هجوم قد نجح تنظيم
ارهابي ما في تنفيذه ولكن لا يعني ذلك ان
الوضع الامني غير مستقر او ان هناك اختراق
امنيوانسه وقع هجوم واحد فقط يتم التعامل
معه هو سيتم الكشف عن تفاصيله حسب ما اكد
الرئيس التركي اردوغان والتصريح وادي
اسطنبول كايا والعديد من الاطراف التي
اكدت متابعه الحادث للوصول الى منفذي بشكل
نهائي
صحفي اعود لك بعد قليل في المحلل السياسي
الاستاذ مصطفى استاذ مصطفى ان كنت تسمعني
طبعا البعض يستبعد او على الاقل يبتعد عن
التشكيك اسمعني يا استاذ مصطفى
طيب
البعض لا يطرح مشكله همم
مشكله الامنيه او على الاقل الاختراق
الامني همم لانه كما تعلم حضرتك كما ذكرنا
منذ قليل المنطقه همم السياحيه بامتياز لا
تشهد تفتيش همم فردي وبالتالي لكل شخص
القدره على الوصول وعلى الدخول وعلى
التجاور ولكن هل هناك فشل استخبارات سهله
همم تنفيذ هذه العمليه
طبعا ليس من الحصول على الاستثمارات ال
الاوليه في هذا المجال
بما يتعلق طبعا
الارهابيه ولكن عندما يكون هناك يعني
حوادث
ارهابيه في هذه الحاله يتم استخراج اضافيه
هذا ما يحدث ولكن اليوم
كان اليوم قال يعني سنوات الماضيه القريبه
كان يقود الان في نهايه تركيا لذلك ربما
لم يلتزم
في امور طبعا
اضافيه
يعني بعد كل عمليه ارهابيه من هذا الشكل
نعلم بانه همم تركيا تتخذ اجراءات عن
المستوى الامني وكذلك على المستوى
الاستخبارات هو ولكن همم تتخذ حتى اجراءات
بداخل في من همم تشك في امكانيه ان يكون
حضوره غير امن لداخل التركي ما المنتظر
بعد هذه العمليه استاذ مصطفى
طبعا لا علاقه يعني
عندما
ينفجر انفجار واحد يتكلم في مع بعض كما
حدثكم بين اتينا 14 و16 كانوا هناك
ارهابيه كبيره قامت به منظمات
ولكن هناك
عسكريه تجاههم في العراق
القادمه
استاذ مصطفى بان هذا الانفجار كذلك ياتي
في فتره همم
حساسيه فما يخص كذلك همم شرق سوري كانت
هناك مشاكل وكانت هناك استفهامات وكانت
هناك حتى بعض التسريبات تتحدث عن امكانيه
ان يكون هناك ارتفاع همم بين النظام
السوري وتركيا والجهه الروسيه على تسهيل
موضوع اشارق السوري هل يمكن لي هذا الملف
همم الشائك ان يكون وراء هذا التفجير
لان
قضيه كوباني
بالنسبه للقيام او همم يعني همم
شمال سوريا
بالنسبه
سوريا سوريا
للقيام بعمل انتقام
يعني لم يخطفون ان ينالوا من ايده سلطان
تركيا
الاحداث نحاول ان نفهم
ونفترض في الواقع في انتظار اي شيء رسمي
يرشح من الجهات الرسميه التركيه ولكن
تحدثنا عن مجموعه كبيره من الاطراف التي
يمكن ان تكون لها مصلحه كما يقول مراقبون
وقد يختلف كذلك مراقبون اخرون على ذلك همم
مصلحه في مثل هكذا انفجار تحدثنا عن
الاخوان تحدثنا عن داعش تحدثنا عن حزب
العمال كردستان يتحدثنا عن مؤيد يا جماعه
ولكن بعض الاخر يطرح فكره نشات همم معرضين
جدد في الداخل التركي منفصلين
همم نشاتهم منذ فتره ويعرضون همم نظام همم
اردوغان ويتحركون فداخل التركي الى اي مدى
هذه الفكره دقيقه
لم يراقب تركيا
في المستقبل
همم
تركيا همم ليس هناك
ولكن طبعا
الغربيه همم
ادي الحوادث من الذهاب المنصلي ولكن حتى
الان لم نشط بعض
استاذ مصطفى
معنا نحن مستمرون في تغطيه انفجار اسطنبول
نذاكر مشاهدينا باننا كنا في متابعه اخر
التفاصيل واخرها اتت على لسان او في
تصريحات الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان
اكد سته قتلى اكثر من 50 جريح 53 جريح
بحسب حاكم اسطنبول في تغريده لا الم في
جار شهيده ميدان تقسيم شارع او جاد
الاستقلال وهذا الشارع الحيوي للغايه
والذي يشهد حضور للسياح مكثف وخاصه في هذه
الفتره على كلن سنبقى في متابعه كل هذه
التصريحات نحن في انتظار اي شيء رسمي
يضعنا في اطار ما يتحدث به الرئيس اردوغان
قال بان امراه هي ظاهره في هذا الانفجار